sean daniels mock draft his new one and
a couple names surprised is there daniel
kind enough to join us let me start with
the running backs here on how you valued
and devalued some of these running backs
Daniel yeah look it's interesting Daniel
kind of you you come out of the combine
and you go down at Indianapolis you get
a chance and all I watch these guys in
the field you a chance to talk to the
teams that have had a chance to visit
with the kids 11 so you get a sense of
who their who their liking and maybe who
they're a little bit concerned about so
when you when you watch those guys run
around I thought McCaffrey definitely is
on the uptick you know Dan you can make
a case watching him go through the
receiver portion of the workout that he
was the best receiver at the combine so
you've got some flexibility with what
you can do with him so I think he's
definitely moving up for net just his
combination of size and speed I think
he's pretty secured to be the first back
off the board and then Dalvin cook who
is a great player on Cape didn't have a
great workout and just when you talk to
people around the league I got a sense
of people really like him but I didn't I
just didn't get the sense that people
were talking about him in the same way
they were about McCaffrey and when I'm
doing those mock drafts again it's not
really how I see the player is it's it's
what i'm hearing and the way I think the
teams will go where does for Ned go I
think you're going to go on the top ten
I think when you look at Jacksonville
potentially could make some sense there
to give them an offensive hammer and
then you also look at Carolina man heat
to me just seems like the perfect fit I
mean you want to close out a game in a
four-minute offense with Cam Newton and
Leonard fournette yeah that's the way to
do it where's McCaffrey go you know I
played around with him in different
places I think he's going to go in the
top 20 damn I think he's just such
unique weapon that you can use I think
the fact that you can play running back
in flame in a slide you can return kicks
and he's so dang smart you're going to
give him a ton of volume and he can
handle it so I think the coaches are
going to fall in love with him and I
think at the end of the day he'll be a
top 20 pics will you have him as 11th
overall billion yeah and it looked at
clear out different scenarios on some of
those the saints are going to they're
going to probably go defense they should
I don't think he'll end up there yeah no
question no question but when you're
putting these things together dan I just
allowed myself to drift off and wonder
what would be like to see Christian
McCaffrey in the slots and briefs see
what could happen all right men Dalvin
cook is he still first-round pick I
think so I think you'll go in the first
round I think one of these guys are
going to slide a little bit and that's
not it it's going to be really because
of the depth more than anything else at
this class is you're going to have team
sitting there saying man I really like I
really like Dalvin cook we can get you
know we can go get the kids in Tennessee
Kamara in the next round we could wait a
couple rounds that we can get Marlon Mac
from South floor there's just so many
backs this year and that's why you've
seen in free agency not a lot of action
with he's running backs not a lot of
money what is Jimmy Garoppolo due to the
first round if he's traded so definitely
which would shake things up because I
think the only team that could really
pull it off would be Cleveland and one
of the main storylines has been all this
draft capital that Cleveland has built
up for this year and next year so I
would imagine it would cost them a good
chunk of that to get garofalo so man if
they will find out we'll find if they
like Jimmy Garoppolo or if they love
Jimmy Garoppolo based on if they get
this done because I think the Patriots
are going to make them pay the lovett
price do you think that he'll be traded
I don't think so just because everything
says that they should trade him and
that's when New England goes in the
other direction so I think New England
just looks at it and says look the
insurance policy for Tom Brady is more
valuable to us than a player we can get
with its walls pick and they may be
right there it's a different way of
thinking but they don't operate like
everybody else all right let's look at
the quarterbacks then because i don't
know i don't think we have a starter in
the bunch at least coming in to start
but the per diem quarterback off the
board is oh man i have Watson but i have
no confidence there in terms of how
that's going to shake out personally how
I've had him stacked up I told you last
time we talked in like I was having
commitment issues trying to land on one
of these guys and then you know watching
more tape and then watching the way
Watson threw it at the combine which
I thought he threw it really well in the
workout it's not even the best feet of
everybody and the interviews from people
i talk to you were off the charts so i
ended up going with Watson as my top
quarterback it's kind of the end of the
process here but i agree with you i
don't think any of them are going to
come in and play right now how's my guy
Solomon Thomas I fell in love with him
he's easy Dan he he's my fourth overall
player in this draft right now and his
work out he ran in the 46 is at 270 plus
pounds all of this stuff was off the
charts and I've got a chance to meet
with him as well he's an impressive kid
so to me I think he's I think he's
locked in at the top 10 pick I'd I take
him in the top five well I watched him
you know that was the bowl game that
McCaffrey wasn't playing in so I tuned
in to see how Stanford would play but
also wanted to see true biscay and then
next thing you know the best player on
the field is Thomas from Stanford yeah
it was the most dominating game by a
defensive lineman this year I mean you
any that I've seen Solomon Thomas again
North Carolina bowl game was the most
dominant performance and then you know
to me like i love the fact the kid it is
the year before when they went to the
Rose Bowl against Iowa they had so many
injuries on the front dan he's 260
pounds and he played the nose for them
in a three-man front which you want to
be 320 pounds to man that position in
that defense didn't complain about it
sucked it up and was actually pretty
darn good in there giving up you know 50
60 pounds a man so that just kind of
speak to a what kind of team guy is but
then just how dang strong he is it's
strange though every year at the combine
we it feels like people are talking
about what they can't have so then this
became more about the quarterback who's
going to be available next year and
right I mean Sam yarnall if Sam Donald's
available now in this draft where's he
going yep well Diana nsl frowns on us
talking about these underclassmen but I
can tell you that he would definitely
only need to bring one cute to
Philadelphia and he might not he might
not get dinner he might have to make
dinner reservations in another city he
would go quickly but everybody was
talking about all Sam darn old man you
know that would be great next year I'm
going no and then next year we're going
to be talking about a quarter
if you can't have until the following
year yeah yeah we'll be talking about
some freshman from from some other
school but the NFL does frown upon they
don't like you talking about somebody
not eligible yeah we don't want they
want to talking about underclassmen
because then we could be you know they
want to upset the relationship with the
colleges that we're encouraging their
players and leave early so that's from
the scouting side of things and then you
know it is the NFL network so I forever
keep to that Dashon Kaiser at Notre Dame
Dan you know look we I thought his 2015
tape was was the best of this draft
class you compare how anybody played
this year last year last year he was as
good as it gets i saw him against texas
he looked like he could be the first
overall pick then it went down for him
it went down for the team and then i'm
still was trying i had him in my top
quarterback i was cleaning to 2015 and
the losses kept piling up and he wasn't
playing well and then we got to the
combine and and I saw him fail a couple
stationary targets I saw his being kind
of all out of whack and I thought I just
at some point time I can't keep going
they're not a first-round draft pick I
think he I think he could go in the
first round in the bottom just because
of that the fact that the team's want
that fifth year on the contract maybe
you see a team kind of come back into
the bottom of the first round but if I
was guessing right now I'd say I think
he's probably more likely to go and
check around great stuff as always we
enjoyed the mock draft and we'll talk to
you soon Thank You Daniel all right Dan
ticker the Dan Patrick show weekday
morning on audience